[Musique]
dernier épisode de notre série consacrée
aux graffitis aujourd'hui on s'intéresse
aux passerelles entre la rue les
ateliers les expositions et le monde de
l'art en général on ira notamment
rencontré deux anciens graffeurs devenu
peintre sur toile et sculpteurs des
salles de classe transformée en salle de
jeux en avril 2019
illustrateur graphiste tatoueur
graffeurs très artiste décor l'ancien
collège anatole bailly dans le cadre du
loir art show l'événement attire 27
mille visiteurs en quatre jours
le graffiti s'invite dans les
expositions et en sens inverse des
artistes comme jean michel ouvrit
investissent aussi la rue moi je suis
illustrateur j'ai vraiment une formation
de design produit design packaging je
fais l'illustration donc je passe mes
journées sur un ordinateur à dessiner à
faire les images sur les tablettes
graphiques lorsqu on est tout seul chez
soi bas le dessin soit ils vont en
galerie il reste pour une des initiés il
reste vraiment pour des micro-niches là
on diffuse massivement le dessin quand
on dessine dans la rue c'est pour tout
le monde donc c'est cadeau vous êtes
obligé de le voir autre exemple des
passerelles entre graffiti et champs
artistiques owni jackson
je me suis mise à la sculpture après
après moi je suis très je suis instable
dans la peinture c'est à dire que je
suis capable de faire des étoiles des
toiles comme ça très ouais c'est pas
fini mais où ces portraits très réaliste
très figuratif
à côté de ça je fais aussi des toiles
spica cela fait beaucoup
pas tous l'ont fait beaucoup mais moi je
j'en fais aussi et je leur prends
régulièrement en fait ce tableau des
ménines longtemps honni a peint les rues
de la ville à la bombe
il est maintenant installé aux ateliers
oulan bator et exposé dans des galeries
un peu partout en france
je dessine en général d'un trait là par
exemple sur la toile tout est fait d'un
trait et puis après j'attaque la
peinture directement fait moi je suis un
peu impatient faut pas que ça faut pas
que ça traîne
c'est un peu l'héritage du graffiti
c'est totalement ça c'est à dire ah
ouais sainté en lien quand
avant on faisait des flops ou des
graffitis fallait que ça évite falek
l'autre et soi juste donc un peu le même
esprit dans l'atelier voisin un autre
graffeurs touche à tout guillaume
garrier peint un de ses tableaux est
actuellement exposée en slovaquie il
sculpte aussi créé des moules à ses
sculptures les reproduit elles sont
ensuite installés directement dans
l'espace public comme ici dans des lieux
symboliques de la capitale
c'est un côté un peu gargouille est ce
que par rapport à l'enseignement où j'ai
eu plus ou moins catholique en pension
je me suis dit que ces voix là c'est une
suite logique en fin de compte nous
l'enseignement mon enseignement à
l'école et de la peinture et voilà j'en
suis arrivée du graffiti au monde de
l'art plus institutionnels les
techniques et les outils évolué mais un
objectif demeure marqué les esprits
nous nous retrouvons aux ateliers oulan
bator à orléans avec honey honey qui a
un passé de graffeurs vandales comment
c'est fait la transition vers la toile
la sculpture en fait il n'y a pas eu
vraiment de transition parce que moi dès
le départ ce que considérer le graffiti
et dessins enfin je mélange et où
j'étais d'ailleurs plus que quelqu'un
qui fait des décors les personnages
j'étais plus dans le dessin avant le
graffiti et du coup dans le graffiti ça
m'a juste permis de faire des dessins
énorme quoi est vu par plein cette mode
street art qu'est ce que tu penses de
cette mode musique douce ou terme aussi
à mon sens à un terme générique qui
était plus ou moins créé par les
galeries pour pouvoir vendre un peu tout
et n'importe quoi du mans qui s'est fait
dans la rue graffiti c'est censé être
moche
enfin c'est pas c'est pas censé être
fait pour plaire et la différence avec
le street art c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui sont fait pour plaire le graffiti
est pas fait pour plaire qui plaisent
pas forcément tu continues de le
regarder de le pratiquer je continue de
le regarder de le pratiquer de temps en
temps et
c'est ce que je trouve le plus en fait
il récupéra en fait c'est quelque chose
que des gens n'aiment pas qui peut pas
être vendue en galerie un taxer ces
salles si l'on se demande pourquoi ces
faits en fait moi ces deux côtés cette
liberté en fait que que j'apprécie merci
beaucoup au nifff voilà c'est la fin de
cette page était consacrée aux graffitis
on espère que ça vous incitera à lever
la tête et regarder autrement ce qui se
fait dans la rue
à bientôt